bienvenue en grèce avec ses teintes de
bleu qui sont des corps des paysans
l'illusion est presque parfaite
on rentre dans un lieu où on est
carrément ailleurs comme ici maintenant
on est en grèce non mais non on est à
montréal sur l'avenue du parc
le restera rhodos fait partie des 250
commerces qui se retrouvent dans québec
un livre sur les endroits kitsch alors
le kitsch est vraiment pas quétaine
kitsch est pas une question de goût en
fait parce que vaille pour certaines
personnes ça peut l'être mais le kitsch
et l'imitation l'immersion
l'accumulation l'excès le toc
le kitsch a pris son essor au québec
dans les années 50
à l'époque certains restaurants saveurs
kitsch était pour des immigrants une
façon de partager leur culture ou elvis
gratton de ce monde fait j'en ai parlé
au chef les hollande
si le spécialiste
c'était une première approche en fait
donc on faisait un décor assez immersif
dans lequel on on répondait finalement
leurs attentes de l'exotisme puis de
cette manière l'homme on pouvait les
attirer on pouvait un ca sur une survie
économique ça c'est quand même assez
important
puis aussi prendre place dans des
quartiers donc je pense que c'était
vraiment réussi à ce niveau là après ce
voyage en grèce transport tourner ou
dans un autre endroit kitsch on est où
il surprend quand on est au snowboard
tiki bar aujourd'hui mais si on était en
1968 on serait à la chouannerie un
restaurant français sur la mer
mais quand même moins on est vraiment
dans l'immersion totale on imite en fait
cette idée de la polynésie mais cette
idée de l'exotisme total puis on est
dans le top 20 dans la saturation des
couleurs des matériaux et ses terrasses
et c'est merveilleux
en regardant bien on trouve toutes
sortes d'objets dans ce bar des objets
produits en syrie et avec un sens de
l'exotisme
enfin ça fait drôle parce que le mot
questions fed viendrait de vercauteren
qui est inquiète un mot allemand puis en
fait elle apparue pendant la révolution
industrielle donc on se mettait à créer
des objets en production massive donc
mettons la vénus de milo mais en
plusieurs plusieurs éditions
et puis tout cette idée de tocqueville
odland les lieux kitsch sans religion au
québec il suffit de les trouver et de se
laisser emporter dans un petit voyage
hors du commun et qui était déjà à la
mode aux jeux s'ouvrent et les yeux phi
phi y aller là ici louis philippe ouimet
radio-canada m'ont rien
[Musique]